then none of these big tech companies
allowed anybody to read the laptop story
in the weeks leading up to that election
now to me that is our government in this
case through the FBI putting Center
blocks on a scale of an election is that
something you would stop and do you
agree with me yeah I would stop in fact
I'm going to issue an executive order
the moment I get into the White House
the first day
forbidding ending the weaponization of
our agency for political
purposes it's ending the machine and the
agencies and their collusion with big
Tech and their assault on the First
Amendment their assault actually on the
Second Amendment their assault really on
all of our foundational documents